en este vídeo vamos a hablar de
soluciones extrañas si nunca has
escuchado este término antes te encargo
que veas algunos vídeos sobre soluciones
extrañas en khan academy pero este es un
pequeño repaso una solución extraña es
la idea de que haces muchas operaciones
algebraicas legítimas y al final llegas
a una solución o algunas soluciones que
cuando las compruebas en tu ecuación
original no las satisfacen entonces la
clave de este vídeo es preguntarnos por
qué obtenemos las soluciones extrañas y
todo esto se debe a la noción de
reversibilidad hay ciertas operaciones
en álgebra que puedes hacer en una
dirección y siempre son ciertas en esta
dirección pero no siempre son ciertas en
la dirección contraria vamos a pensar en
esas dos operaciones
una de ellas es elevar al cuadrado y la
otra es multiplicar de ambos lados por
una expresión variable primero pensemos
en el ejemplo de elevar al cuadrado y
vamos a ver un escenario donde
trabajamos con una solución extraña por
ejemplo sabemos que si a es igual a b
puedo elevar al cuadrado ambos lados y
por lo tanto obtengo que a cuadrada es
igual a b cuadrada pero en la dirección
contraria no es cierto por ejemplo sea
cuadrada es igual a de cuadrada no
siempre es el caso que sea igual a p
cuál es un ejemplo donde veamos que esto
no es siempre es cierto
de hecho pausa el vídeo y piénsalo un
poco
bueno menos 2 elevado al cuadrado en
efecto es igual a 2 elevado al cuadrado
pero menos 2 no es igual a 2 es decir lo
que esto nos dice es que puede hacerle
para ambos lados de una ecuación y
deducir algo que es cierto pero la
dirección contraria no es necesariamente
cierta
otra operación que algunas veces no es
reversible es multiplicar de ambos lados
por una variable multiplicar de ambos
lados por una variable y escribir
variable pero también puede ser una
expresión variable por ejemplo si
sabemos que a es igual a b y
multiplicamos de ambos lados por una
variable
esto seguirá siendo cierto x por a es
igual a x por b pero la dirección
contraria no es siempre cierta si x por
a es igual a x por b es siempre el caso
que hace igual a b bueno la respuesta es
simple no y como siempre te encargo que
pausas el vídeo e intentes encontrar un
ejemplo donde esto no pase qué pasa si a
es igual a 2 y b es igual a 3 y la
variable x tiene el valor de cero
sabemos que en efecto 0 por 2 es igual a
0 por 3 pero dos no es igual a 3 ahora
cómo se conecta todo esto con las
soluciones extrañas que vemos cuando
resolvemos ecuaciones radicales o
ecuaciones con expresiones racionales de
ambos lados bueno veamos un ejemplo
vamos a trabajar con una ecuación
radical si quiero resolver la ecuación
la raíz cuadrada de 5 x 4 es igual a x
menos 2 la forma típica de resolver es
elevar al cuadrado ambos lados así que
elevamos al cuadrado ambos lados y
obtengo que 5 x 4 es igual a x cuadrada
menos 4 x + 4 una vez más si esto te
parece poco familiar vamos a profundizar
en este tema en otros vídeos
pero esta vez estamos introduciendo la
idea de ecuaciones radicales y bueno
podemos restar 5x de ambos lados y sumar
4 de ambos lados para intentar tener 0
del lado izquierdo de la ecuación y así
obtengo que 0 es igual a x cuadrada
menos 9 x + 8 y 0 es igual a x menos 8
por x menos uno o podemos decir que x
menos 1 es igual a cero o x menos 8 es
igual a cero de lo que obtenemos que x
es igual a 1 y x es igual a 8
bueno ahora vamos a comprobar las
soluciones si sustituimos x igual a 8 en
color rojo que obtenemos en la ecuación
original bueno obtengo que la raíz
cuadrada de 36 es igual a 6 lo que es
completamente cierto así que esta
solución funciona
qué hay de x1 nos queda la raíz cuadrada
de 5 por 14 lo cual es igual a 1 la raíz
cuadrada de uno es uno y esto es igual a
uno menos dos que es igual a menos uno
esta solución no funciona esta es una
solución extraña y si te preguntarán
cuáles son todos los valores que
satisfacen la ecuación no debes dar en
tu respuesta a x igual a 1 aunque le
hayamos obtenido con pasos algebraicos
legítimos y la razón del por qué pasa
esto
de hecho pausa el vídeo y piensa para
cuáles de estos pasos funciona la
solución x igual a 1 y para qué paso
deja de funcionar
bueno podrás observar que x igual a 1
funciona para todos estos pasos después
de la recta en morado y para el único
paso que no funciona es para la ecuación
la raíz cuadrada de 5x menos 4 es igual
a x menos 2 puedes empezar con x igual a
1 y cumplir todos estos pasos hasta la
recta de aquí pero el problema es que
elevar al cuadrado no es una operación
reversible esto sana lo va a decir oye
sabemos que ha elevado al cuadrado es
igual a b elevado al cuadrado sabemos
que esto es igual a esto pero sabemos
que no es necesariamente igual a p para
x igual a 1
y podemos hacer lo mismo con ecuaciones
que tengan expresiones racionales por
ejemplo queremos resolver x cuadrada
entre x menos 1 es igual a 1 entre x
menos 1 lo primero que queremos hacer es
multiplicar a ambos lados por x menos 1
multiplicar por x menos 1 y queremos
multiplicar a ambos lados por una
expresión variable así que tenemos que
ser un poco conscientes pero si de todas
las formas multiplicamos ambos lados por
x menos 1 entonces obtengo que x 4
desigualdad 1 o podemos decir que x es
igual a 1 o x es igual a menos 1
pero podemos comprobar en la ecuación
que para x igual a 1
estoy dividiendo de ambos lados por 0
así que esta es una solución extraña la
clave es que multiplicamos a ambos lados
por una expresión variable en este caso
multiplicamos ambos lados por x menos 1
y podemos hacerlo podemos multiplicar de
ambos lados por una expresión variable
de hecho es una operación algebraica
legítima pero la dirección opuesta no
siempre es cierta es completamente
análogo a lo que vemos acá abajo ten
cuidado sólo porque 0 por 2 es igual a 0
por 3 eso no significa que 12 es igual a
3 10 completamente análogo porque
estamos multiplicando por una expresión
variable que evalúa al valor de cero
cuando x es igual a 1
así que el panorama general es entender
un poco más por qué pasan las soluciones
extrañas cuando elevas al cuadrado o
multiplicas ambos lados por una
expresión variable es completamente
legítimo mientras lo realices de manera
correcta pero no siempre es cierto que
la dirección opuesta sea verdadera
puedes sumar o restar lo que sea de
ambos lados de una ecuación y esa
operación será siempre reversible esa
operación no nos dará soluciones
extrañas pasa lo mismo al multiplicar o
dividir por una constante distinta de
cero eso no nos dejará nada sospechoso
pero si elevas al cuadrado o multiplicas
ambos lados por una expresión variable
debes tener un poco de cuidado